[Música]
[Aplausos]
hay tantos cualquiera
nací en la localidad de caquiaviri en la
comunidad limpia
a 89 km del departamento de la paz
es el lugar remoto me vio crecer es el
lugar remoto me vio crecer como niño o
como adolescente
tengo cinco hermanos
y mi padre mauricio
agricultor siempre nos decía
la única oportunidad que nosotros
teníamos era que teníamos que estudiar
porque era el único camino para salir
adelante
recuerdo a margarita mi mamá a las 5 de
la mañana
ella preparaba los huevos a la copa
mientras nosotros nos alistábamos la
mochila
el guardapolvo
y nos decían tienen que tomar este huevo
la copa el día va a ser el día va a ser
muy largo necesitan energía
necesitan volver
como qué
ahí estaba la mediana lista y nosotros a
las seis y media la mañana más o menos
tenemos que salir al trote rumbo a este
pueblito caquiaviri con la única
necesidad de poder aprender de poder
encontrarnos con nuestros compañeros que
muchos de ellos igual venían de
comunidades lejanas
el vecino más cercano si quieres
llamémoslo vivían mínimo a dos
kilómetros y medio de distancia de la
casa mis padres
pero eso no me impedía a que estos cinco
hermanos salgan para adelante
mi papá siempre nos decía
nosotros tenemos que ayudar a la gente
el jactaba porque nosotros
éramos adolescentes
llenos de energía
ok mañana hay que ir a ayudar
a don alberto
porque necesita la ayuda de ustedes
porque si no van a ustedes ayudará a
recoger la cosecha la cosecha se va a
torcer
así nacía
esas cosas es tan intuitiva de mi padre
para que la comunidad no se muera él
decía si nosotros no ayudamos la
comunidad se nos murió
recuerdo mis vacaciones
mi papá mi mamá nos decían
hay que llevar los ganados a la montaña
porque era el lugar donde pasábamos
nosotros
y éramos adolescentes
pero teníamos la responsabilidad de
hacernos cargo de esas más de 100
ganados de oveja llamas que estaban a
nuestro cargo
tenemos que aprender a cocinar a lidiar
con el tiempo
pero había que disfrutarlo a la vez
hemos sido responsables de ese de ese
ganado que nuestro padre nos entregó
porque en ese ganado estaba un poquito
de ingreso para buscar los mejores días
para nosotros
fue una enseñanza
con lo poco que había lo disfrutábamos
lo pasamos tan bien pero a la vez
lo único que buscábamos era cuando
empieza el colegio
porque en el momento de encontrarnos con
nuestros compañeros y vaya muchos de mis
amos muchos de mis
vecinos no tuvieron esa misma
oportunidad
un día
a mí se me abre una ventana en el ámbito
gastronómico
un chef llamado chardy ledesma un día se
encuentra y me dice santos como te ves
aquí de aquí a 15 días aquí a 10 años y
le dije no sé te invito a la cocina para
que seas parte de nuestro equipo
no lo dude en ese día al día siguiente
estuve media hora antes esperando que se
abra esa ventana y con esa necesidad
como yo vi al fondo lluvias a esa cocina
esos señores vestidos de blanco todos
trabajando de forma tan ordenada tan yo
dije yo quiero estar acá
eso fue el inicio
para sumergirme en este mundo culinario
la gastronomía me formó la gastronomía
me educó mediante la gastronomía conocí
mi familia mi esposa mis hijos la
gastronomía me hizo viajar por el país
la gastronomía miso hablar fuera de mi
país hablar de mis insumos de lo que
teníamos
mi padre siempre decía siempre es bueno
capacitarse siempre es bueno aprender
un día
se abre otra gran ventana en mi camino
donde nace mi empresa
pasionaria
en tan poco tiempo
estaba a mi cargo más de 74 trabajadores
y teníamos un verano donde el parque
recibía entre 800 a 1.200 personas día
pero las cosas cambiaban había que
replantear había que planificar había
que organizar había que prever lo que se
venía tanto me ha servido capacitarme sí
me apoye en la gente que trabajaba
conmigo los empodere para que ellos se
identifiquen ellos se identifiquen con
la compasión aria eso me ayudó
a poder sobrellevar más de cuatro años y
medio
esta empresa ofreciendo servicio y para
buscando que la gente tenga un día muy
lindo en ese en ese parque
pero los sueños no terminan ahí
soy cocinero
debo seguir a mi lucha
vine de abajo
pero quería algo más
es donde nace
pasionaria by santos
un restaurante
pensado
en hacer un diálogo directo con la gente
un restaurante donde buscamos
interactuar con el visitante con el
comensal que ir a pasionaria sea parte
de una experiencia culinaria
hay que arriesgar
desde el diego no lo hicimos
buscamos todo el equipamiento necesario
para que la gente que va a trabajar
conmigo se sienta a gusto
para que la gente cuando venga a
visitarnos
celebre emociones sevilla se lleve
recuerdos
que ir a comer a pasionaria
sea el momento esperado y así fue
no nos cansamos de capacitar a la gente
no nos cansamos de
de trabajar antes de la apertura a
puerta cerrada esto es el menú estos son
los pasos que vamos a seguir esto va a
ser la ruta
que vamos a seguir todos los días y así
fue
nuestra experiencia en este tiempo fue
maravilloso
porque a cambio de eso lo único que
recibíamos
lo más lindo era la felicidad la
satisfacción de ese comensal
un día
en mi camino
se abre otra gran ventana
yo me tenía que capacitar yo necesitaba
renovarme yo necesitaba aprender más
desde que me inicié en el mundo
culinario siempre soñé con ser parte
algún día de la escuela le cordon bleu
del perú intenté una vez dos veces y en
la tercera lo logré lo disfruté con
tanta pasión con la misma energía de mi
niñez
recuerdo ese pasillo largo en mi último
día de examen de grado con mi plato y ha
terminado
y dije estoy aquí
pero tan pronto también eligió dije esto
me corresponde
lo luche me lo gané
dime poder
de ese momento de que esas seis semanas
no fueron en vano
volví cargado de grandes emociones
soñaba con ministro en alguna esquina de
equipetrol para tener un diálogo directo
con la gente para expresarme mediante la
comida mis emociones con la gente pero
se vino esa gran ventana
quien nunca había esperado la pandemia
un día con mi esposa maría paula
vimos un emprendimiento de solidaridad
de un amigo nuestro ernesto
y dijimos y por qué no llevamos comida a
la gente que más lo necesita si tenemos
todo
tan pronto había pasado
habían pasado 13 semanas
y habíamos llevado habíamos alimentado a
más de 72 mil personas
claro
paula y santos se unieron con los hijos
y cada uno tenía más o menos y casi
igual de principios de nuestros padres
que nos enseñaban sus valores
de la solidaridad
trabajamos arduamente
planificando un menú semanal
pero shanta curso es maravillosa la
gente ustedes se acercaron me apoyaron y
fue en el vehículo en llegar a los más
necesitados
fueron momentos muy duros a la vez
fueron momentos donde nos acercamos a la
gente para motivarlos para decirles de
que no pronto cómo salir adelante
la cocina
es noble
todo lo que aprendí tenía que poner en
práctica
en este corto tiempo
la cocina
es auténtica la gente allá en el barrio
más lejano debería de recibir el trato
con la misma pasión
con este plato caliente noble pues
nadie un día que nosotros dejemos de
hacer
un día
en medio de la pandemia
si habrá otra gran ventana
no me puedo detener
debo seguir
mientras seguíamos
años atrás
en los banquetes en las reuniones los
cócteles unos bocadillos tan bien
elaborados con mucho cariño y salían
unos patés la gente se me preguntaba
dónde lo conseguiste donde lo compraste
quienes sean los hago yo
pues en la pandemia un día charlando con
paula dijimos por qué no vendemos esto
porque no probamos
es importante escuchar la opinión de un
tercero
hicimos pruebas para k pruebas por allá
y puedo decir
con mucho orgullo de que nuestros
pasteles han nacido en la pandemia
y han cruzado nuestras fronteras
como cocinero
siempre voy a volver a mis principios
la cocina
necesita talento la cocina es emoción es
la cocina es un mundo donde no hay un
final
pero estamos destinados nosotros como
cocineros
al satisfacer esas grandes necesidades
yo no sé mañana quién espera
pero lo que me va a esperar
voy a encarar con la misma pasión
con la misma energía
porque esos valores me enseñó mi padre
esos valores los aprendí de pequeño que
lo poco que había
o lo poco que teníamos había que darle
al máximo
me siento afortunado
de que me deje de ser parte de este
mundo culinario me siento afortunado de
seguir probando mis desafíos
pero la puerta que venga
lo voy a esperar con la misma pasión
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]